608 on your thursday morning we've all
seen those people spinning signs on
street corners trying to get your
attention for one business or another
well for some of them it's not a
part-time gig and there's even a sign
spinning competition our bialco holman
live in downtown las vegas and bianca
you've been talking about giving it a
spin are we going to see you give it a
try here
oh yes you're going to see it but i got
to give you all the lay of the land and
what this competition is all about so
i'm joined by ryan jones who is the gm
of the aero sign spinners here in las
vegas so tell us more about this
competition that is happening this
saturday so we have sign spinners coming
from all around the world to compete to
see who the best sign spread in the
world is the top spinners from each of
our markets had a competition and now we
got him to vegas and we're going to have
a world science spinning championship so
this is the 15th year right y'all have
been doing this for a long time
that's new correct it's the 20th
anniversary as well for our company so
yeah it's going to be big yeah and so
also just tell us how are people judged
so they're judged on their technical
ability their style and then how well
they actually perform on their rounds
all right so i had gerald gerald come on
over here he taught me a trick y'all
been waiting i've been teasing to it
ryan's gonna hold the mic okay
watch
perfect
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah bianca right what what score would
you give that rand what score and it
would be a 10.
across the board
good stuff back to you guys in the
studio all right very well bianca